leaders of the wealthiest democracies
have
agreed on a plan to counter china's
global influence
the first face-to-face g7 summit since
the pandemic began
has showcased a newfound western unity
day two of the talks in southwest
england focused on holding back the
rising power
of authoritarian states such as china
and russia the third and final day will
wrap up with pledges of cash to help
fight climate change
even environmental protesters who turned
out to
criticize the pace of climate action had
words of welcome
for the u.s president i'm really glad
that joe biden
has brought back this spirit of
multilateralism that the leaders are now
actually talking to each other and
the idea of climate denial is off the
table tackling climate change is one of
the issues french president emmanuel
macron says will be easier
now that washington wants to partner up
we have to face a lot of changes
a lot of crisis climate change
and um and for all these issues what we
need is cooperation
and i think it's great to have a
the u.s president part of the club and
uh
are willing to to to cooperate i think
we can do a lot too we uh
the united states i've said before we're
back the us is back we feel
very very strongly about the cohesion of
nato and
i for one think that the european union
is an incredibly strong and
vibrant entity the spirit of cooperation
is working for biden as he won
g7 support for the build back better
world initiative
which will mobilize public and private
capital to help close a 40 trillion
dollar infrastructure gap with
developing countries
the u.s wants to create a counterweight
to chinese investment
although german chancellor angela merkel
emphasized the plan is not against
beijing
it's for assisting poorer countries
we know there's a huge need for
infrastructure in africa for example
it's in our interest that africa
develops in an economically sensible
way you can't just say china will do it
merkel also called on her fellow g7
leaders to share more coronavirus
vaccines with developing countries
the group is expected to finalize
commitments to preventing future
pandemics
in their summit communiques sunday
dw correspondent alexander von nahman
has been reporting
throughout from cornwall where the g7
summit is taking place
this weekend alexandra day three will
soon get underway how productive has the
summit been so far
well at first view you would say the
summit has been
quite productive the leaders have
adopted a declaration
to prevent future pandemics they have
pledged to
donate at least 1 billion vaccine doses
they are ready to launch a new
infrastructure
initiative however we also have to say
that those declaration
are non-binding declarations and uh
we also have to keep in mind that uh
such meetings are not only about
concrete results when we consider that
g7
started as a fireplace meeting so
g7 is also about coming together
talking face to face trying to build
rapport and this meeting
meeting is particular particularly about
welcoming joe biden as the new us
president and it is supposed to send a
strong
signal that the g7 leaders are
united and ready ready to take on
uh the current challenges you know i'm
curious that uh
infrastructure project aimed at
countering uh china's global influence
sounds very ambitious
what more can you tell us about it
it sounds very ambitious indeed the plan
is to raise
hundreds of millions or even hundreds of
billions in both public and private
money to invest
in the infrastructure of poorer
countries
and roads and and bridges but also
in their digital and health
infrastructure
and the us was pushing for those for
this initiative to be adopted
because they see it as an alternative
western alternative to china's
highly criticized belt and road
initiative scheme
however some european leaders are still
very cautious we just heard from german
chancellor angel
angela merkel she was trying to play
down this initiative a bit saying it's
not against beijing and it's just about
establishing a task force
first so as you can see european leaders
are very cautious because
they regard china not only as a rival
and competitor but also as a partner
on global issues that's a dw
correspondent alexander von naman from
the g7 summit in southwestern england
many thanks
crossing to china now where
correspondent matthias bolinga is
standing by
in beijing matia said china has
criticized g7 plans to create a green
belt and road plan
to counter china's influence beijing
says the days when global decisions were
dictated by a small group of countries
are long gone
how does china feel about being
increasingly perceived as a competitor
by the west
well this is definitely something that
uh
china is worried about i mean before
this this meeting is just one of the
series of events that have been
happening in the last
four or five years that were aimed
at maybe restricting china's influence
in the world or countering
china's more assertive policies let's
just uh remember
the south china sea that china is now
claiming
entirely as its own waters let's uh
talk about uh the uh policy in hong kong
uh uh where it has ended
the system that was guaranteed before
let's talk about the human rights
violations
in xinjiang and its more aggressive
policies
towards taiwan that it regards as its
own territory
and all and this combined with a very
much
more aggressive tone by chinese
diplomats this statement that you've
just quoted that was issued
by the embassy in london is very calm
and very toned down compared to some
other things we have heard in the past
few years all this is a sign that
china sees itself increasingly also
in a battle in a in a concurrence uh a
competition with the west and uh
this is a this is a mutual feeling i
would say
yeah you have a completely different
perspective there in asia than one does
have here in europe so
does the change in administrations in
washington
from president trump to his successor
joe biden
make any difference to china
well i think people the the
establishment in china the
foreign policy establishment is
understanding that this was not a one
uh one-time pet project by
an unpredictable american president but
that confrontation
a confrontational approach to china's
rise is part
of the american policy before i am not
sure
who believed what who was how convinced
that the policies
would softer be softer on china with
biden
but at least that was what some of the
state media have been saying once this
trump
period is over things will get to what
they were before they clearly
have not and um it seems at least the
chinese public
is perceiving this now and is partly
surprised or is taking
this a lot more serious and for now
a lot of people rally around the chinese
government on
this issue which is always it's always
hard to say whether this is a majority
or not because a lot of other voices are
censored
but china is realizing now that the
things have really
changed in the west that's uh matthias
of berlinger in
beijing thanks so much